hello my name is chris wendt from
microsoft research
we have this product called microsoft
translator with an extension called the
microsoft translator hub
and our users ask us many questions
about the right way to evaluate the
quality
of machine translation and the quality
of their own customized machine
translation
dr will lewis from the microsoft
translator team is here with us
to shed some light right to the first
question what is the purpose
of evaluating the quality of automatic
translation
and what are our users able to do with
this no that's a that's a very good
question
so to answer that question i mean as you
know automatic translation is used
uh in a variety of scenarios for
translating uh documents from one
language
into another language and
the reason for translating documents
automatically could be that you want to
translate them
for direct human consumption you might
want to translate them in a post-editing
scenario where
the output is actually then edited by a
human for
subsequent consumption or maybe to
generate output that
other machines might use for data mining
or extraction of content or what have
you
so is the basis of an evaluation
always a previously done human
translation do i always need to have
that in order to make an evaluation
yes generally we want to have a human
translation to compare against so
automatic metrics typically use
as a reference a human translation and
you compare the quality of the
output from the machine translation
engine against that human reference
and we can measure factors such as just
a you know some
very generic difference between the
reference and the machine translation
output or we can look at other factors
such as
linguistic quality word order and other
things that actually
we can measure but since the
point of machine translation is to
generate output that is
understandable and readable by humans we
use as our reference point
human translations well can you walk us
through the different methods
of automatically scoring the quality of
translation i understand there's
automatic scoring as well as
other methods let's look at the
automatic scoring methods
first so can you give us an overview of
that yeah so
there are multiple methods for automatic
scoring the basic notion of automatic
scoring is to have
a reference that you actually compare
against and then you generate what we
call a score
so there's a there's an actual number
assigned to
the difference between the machine
translation output
and the human translation reference
and there are multiple methods that are
actually used for
automatic evaluation the point of
automatic evaluation is
that it's fast and cheap if if i want to
look at multiple
languages say in comparison are these
automatic scoring methods giving me any
indication
that allows me to compare between
languages so is is a score comparable
between language a
and language b the automatic scoring
method that's typically used or the and
that we use is blue
spelled b l e u and the blue score is
basically an automatic method that
looks at the machine translation output
and human reference
what about comparing the quality of a
say a rule-based machine translation
engine and the statistical
machine translation engine does the blue
score
or any automatic score help me there the
kind of fundamental
uh comparison point for blue is the word
and so
and it's kind of a statistical it's
biased towards statistical engines so
phrase based engines tend to fare better
in blue than
than rule-based engines so if you have a
score
of a certain number on a rule-based
engine and comparing it against
a phrase-based engine isn't exactly fair
because the rule-based engine will be
penalized
which scoring method do you use at
microsoft for instance to improve
bing translator the method that we use
in bing translator is actually a blue
score as i mentioned earlier
uh spelled bleu and a blue square is a
measure
of the difference between the human
translation
and the machine translation output and
it looks at uh
the presence or absence of particular
words as well as their ordering
and the uh degree of distortion how how
much they actually are
are separated in the uh in the output
the blue score is typically measured on
a zero to one scale
so it's a it's a effectively a
probability that's assigned
to that output and we oftentimes
multiply that number by a hundred
and give it as a percent so we'll talk
about a blue score of say
35 or a blue score of of 42
and that more or less means that we've
taken the the actual output and
multiplied it by a hundred
so 100 would mean per a perfect match
yes
zero would mean that there is no single
word
the same in that that's a good point
absolutely so the blue score measures
the difference between the input and
output if there's no words in common
between the human the machine translated
output
and the human translated reference then
it will be assigned a score of zero
if they're exactly the same including
the order uh
of the translation then it gets a score
of one
or one hundred can you explain the
difference between
auto differences between automatic
evaluation and
and and human scoring yes absolutely so
a blue has been shown to be highly
correlated with human evaluations
that's one of the reasons we're able to
use it because we can use it as a
surrogate for
an actual human evaluation but
some of the problems with blue is it's
very sensitive to
the words that are present in the input
or excuse me in the output of the
machine
translation engine so if we
break the words differently
using what's called a word breaker from
um
in our machine translation output it can
actually give us a different blue score
word breaking sounds like it would be
something that's fairly trivial and
actually it isn't
and it's especially not trivial with
languages such as chinese
or thai where the notion of word is
flexible or where the notion of word is
not completely clear
blue it's important that you basically
take into account what word breakers
being used
and between uh the comparisons that
you're doing
i have the different machine translation
vendors called different
low scores uh to me what else do i need
to watch out
for when when somebody quotes a blue
score to me
and it gets back first of all since we
talked about word breakers already
uh the word breaker obviously has an
impact on uh
uh the qual the blue score that's
actually quoted so that needs to be
taken into account
typically if you have multiple
references the blue score tends to be
higher
so if you hear a very large blue score
someone gives you a value that seems
very high
you can ask them if there are multiple
references that are being used because
then that
is the reason that the score is actually
higher so what is the test that's
that's being used uh so a blue score
by itself really is not as mean
is not meaningful in isolation you need
to really have to know what
what's being tested as well what is the
test set
so if you're comparing uh blue scores
between two different systems and there
are two different test sets that are
being used then they're not they're not
comparable uh scores you need to be
measuring against
a standard test set or uh be using the
same test set in both scenarios
or probably it makes sense to use my own
test yeah that comes out of my own
application scenario absolutely if you
have
uh your own test set and have the
ability to measure it against another
engine for instance
that is going to be the most meaningful
result especially if that test set is
representative of the translations that
you want to produce
from your particular machine translation
engine in microsoft translator hub
i'm getting a blue score after every
training that that i'm doing what is it
telling me
so the blue score that you receive after
training gives you a sense of the
quality of that particular machine
translation that you've built so
each training will produce a different
blue score
so the blue score then gives you a sense
of
the improvement how you're actually how
the engine is actually improving and
gives you a sense of what the direction
that you actually want to go in
so higher blue scores are better
i always see two numbers so i see the i
see the blue score and
at a say a negative or a positive number
behind that
what does that tell me okay so uh the
blue score in the hub basically is
measured not only against
your engine it's also measuring against
our generic purpose
engine basically one that's not trained
on your particular data
so the difference you you see there is a
difference between your engine
and the generic engine it also you can
compare
uh uh different iterations of your
engine as well over time so can you
compare
your engine now against the uh the
training that you did
let's say a week ago we talked about the
the the test set the blue score being
relative to
the test set when i design
my test set what do i need to pay
attention to so the hub allows me to
to either have the hub automatically
select the test set
or give me a chance to
define my own right let's say i define
my own what would
how would i do that and what's the
purpose of that okay
the hub automatically as you ment as you
indicated
automatically you can actually tell it
to automatically generate your own test
set
by doing that it basically samples
sentences
from your training data to produce a
test set that you can continue
can continue to use now one of the
things it does when it actually samples
that test set
is to ensure that that the test data
that's in that test set
does not overlap with the data that's in
the training data
and that's actually very important uh so
if you're producing your own test set
you need to ensure
that the test data in your test set do
not overlap with the training data that
you're training on
that actually invalidates the results if
they actually do overlap
you also want to have a test set that's
representative of
the kinds of translations that you want
to do so what
what is it that you want to output what
is the kind of documents that you're
going to be passing through your engine
you want
your test set to be as representative as
possible
of the kind of content that you're
actually going to be translating using
your engine
that's good that's an interesting aspect
i need to make a good guess
of what i'm going to translate in the in
the future and choose what looks
very similar well you want to measure
the quality improvements or the quality
on
content that matters to you not some
other content that doesn't
isn't relevant yeah well in addition to
the test data
the hub also asks me to define tuning
data and i can either
have that selected automatically or i
can submit my own
tuning set what is this tuning data used
for
that's a very good question tuning data
is
is basically another kind of training
data it's used to set
the large number of parameters that are
used by the machine translation to
generate its output
so it's another kind of training data
now typically
tuning data is drawn from the same set
of material or the same content as your
test data is
you want them to kind of match because
basically the tuning data is used
to set the parameters to make the
machine translation
engine do better on data that looks like
the tuning data
so if your test data is like your tuning
data then you're going to do better on
your test data because of that
it's also important that your tuning
data not overlap
with your training data so that the
content is distinct between the two
and that your tuning data does not
overlap with your test data either it
can be the same kind of content but it
can't be the exact
same content that makes sense but
why can't i just use the tuning data to
also give me the
give me the score because tuning data is
training data
you don't want to use the tuning data as
your test data
so you need to have a an independent
source of testing data yeah so you get
you get really useful scores only if you
keep it clean so just
that's that's you don't contaminate your
your test with what you used previously
that's right
in building the engine i mean the the
engine when it's actually training does
use
does calculate blue scores for instance
against that tuning data
that's part of the mechanism that it
uses to basically maximize the value on
that
on that tuning data the microsoft
translator hub gives me the option to
train on a particular project
repeatedly presumably with the with the
intent of me
changing something in between so what
are the things i can change what are the
things i should change in order to
optimize the system for my
for my purpose you often will make
changes between each
training you'll make changes to the data
so what you want to do is to
have the best selection of data to give
you
the the best blue score the best output
for your test set adding in documents or
removing documents maybe that aren't
helping
and then retraining can help you to
basically improve
uh your blue score over time it might be
that you've decided that you want to
increase the size of your tuning set or
you have some additional content you
want to add to that tuning set
what you typically don't want to do is
change your test data
because if you change your test data
then you invalidate the previous results
you're not going to be able to directly
compare
the results from your current test set
against an older test set
now you may want to change the test set
at some point but you
you don't want to do that with each
training you want to keep the test set
constant
and then change the other parameters
that you can change which are
your training data and your tuning data
good so i did that a couple of times
on my english french project i got a
score of 32.6
what does it mean 32.6 is that good or
bad
i can't say whether 32.6 is is a good
blue score or a bad blue score it kind
of depends on the scenario
and it depends on comparisons against
what you've trained before
we talked about the automatic evaluation
now but you also mentioned the the
option of human evaluation
what is that good for the ultimate test
of a machine translation
engine is human eval we basically want
the
the uh want to have a sense of how good
that engine is
or how the engine is perceived by humans
how good the output is
for human consumption now at microsoft
we basically use
a one to four scale for measuring the
quality of the machine translation
output using human evaluators
one means that it's uh not good at all
it's a
really bad translation four means it's
perfect it means it's really good
uh and we typically have a set of four
evaluators
and we we have them evaluate the output
and then they each assign scores to the
output four set
of sentences within a test set and then
we average across
those sets of evaluated so well now we
talked about
the the absolute scoring that gives me
just one one one score
on the test set uh what else can
one do or what else do you do with the
human evaluators yeah
well often we actually don't just look
at uh
at absolute scores on a particular
engine we'll look at
uh differences so relative scores
between like two iterations of the same
engine
or uh comparative scores from this
engine to say
some competitors engine and that
actually is is
really useful we'll actually have the
human evaluators look at the
the output from two different engines
and then assign a score
relative to each of them so you'll get a
one to four
uh number of some type for each engine
and that actually proves to be quite
useful
in uh doing evals uh in these kinds of
scenarios yeah so that the judge then
looks at the human reference
that's right and the output from engine
one and the output
that's absolutely that's absolutely true
we can also
uh if we have bilingual evaluat
bilingual evaluators we can have them
actually look
at the source too and then make a
judgment call as to what the quality of
the uh the
translation output is and then we're
asking them to assign scores based
on their judgments about the quality so
it's not necessary to hire
experts uh in this field to basically do
the human event
in a way you don't want them to be
experts you want them to be regular
users or
potential users of your service thank
you well that makes
perfect sense to me and it answered
answered my questions that i had for you
today
and i hope it answered your questions as
well
thank you very much for watching this
conversation thank you
each year microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world
including leading scientists renowned
experts in technology
book authors and leading academics and
makes videos of these lectures freely
available